today we're going to talk about some
natural beta blockers now what is a beta
blocker
well a beta blocker is something that
inhibits or blocks
beta adrenergic receptors
which are certain receptors for
adrenaline so basically it blocks the
stress response which is part of the
sympathetic nervous system
and doctors prescribe beta blockers for
various conditions number one to help
slow down the heartbeat
for abnormal heartbeats arrhythmias
for high blood pressure
for second heart attacks for angina
which is chest pain
for essential tremors if your hands are
shaking and the word essential means
unknown cause so they don't know what
causes this type of tremor also mitral
valve prolapse
and a condition called pots where you
get dizzy if you stand up
and it's been used for anxiety as well
all right so the problem is there are
some
side effects from taking a beta blocker
so i'm going to talk about some natural
beta blockers
which are certain remedies to reduce
adrenaline now of course adrenaline is
part of the
stress response so anything you can do
to reduce stress be a very good thing so
the first thing i'm going to recommend
is potassium to increase your potassium
potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms the nervous system
down number two garlic garlic has
properties to reduce blood pressure and
it can also help reduce adrenaline also
garlic is loaded with vitamin b1 which
is another remedy thiamine b1 is a great
natural remedy to help lower the stress
response
it can reduce both cortisol and
adrenaline then we have magnesium which
is another mineral that helps calm the
nervous system and by the way calcium is
not something you want to take if you're
trying to lower adrenaline it can
increase adrenaline
because calcium is part of the
contraction mechanism whereas magnesium
is part of the relaxation mechanism
all right the next one is vitamin d
vitamin d is really good to help reduce
cortisol as well as adrenaline as part
of the stress response and a great herb
to take which is an adaptogen
for the adrenals which can help reduce
cortisol as well as adrenaline is
ashwagandha now the next thing i would
highly recommend to do is do long walks
okay every day it's going to help calm
the nervous system down it's going to
help reduce stress increase oxygen
and i would recommend doing my
acupressure if you're not familiar with
it i put a link down below of how to do
it but it can help reduce stress and
calm the nervous system
which adrenaline is a part of
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
droid so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others